>>Hello.
This year's annual meeting's theme is Rethink,
Redesign, Rebuild.
And I think when considering this very nice
themes, I would like to
raise the question of state sovereignty.
I think it is a good time to redefine the
concept of state sovereignty
in a way that oppressive government would
not be able to oppress their
people, to violate their people.
A government such as Iran government, especially
since fraudulent
election, cracking down protest, trying to,
you know, terrorize people
to stop coming to the street and to protest
the against the state.
So this is responsibility of international
community to take, you know,
responsibility, to raise and criticize Iran's
government regarding
human rights violation.
Here are other few countries that are oppressing
their people so I
think it is time to raise and to redefine
the concept of state
sovereignty.
I hope at the final report of the annual meeting
we could see
reflection of this new definition on the final
report.
Thank you.